on va passer tout de suite à info ou
intox
anthony saint léger bonsoir bonsoir
audrey bonsoir a tous très heureux de
vous retrouver pour la rentrée d'infos
ou intox une nouvelle saison placée sous
le signe de la nouveauté parce que
désormais chaque soir cet écran tactile
nous accompagnera vous accompagnera pour
pointer du doigt les uns fox est
déconstruit par la rédaction des
observateurs de france 24
de votre chronique alors que certaines
politiques certains politiques français
certaines politiques françaises aussi
mettre en cause l'existence l'existence
de crimes de guerre commis par la russie
en ukraine à des internautes évoquait
déjà il ya quelques semaines des mises
en scène fait pour accuser l'armée russe
expliquez nous effectivement ce sont
essentiellement des publications qui
nous viennent de comptes twitter
francophone et anglophone depuis le 12
août environ à l'instar de cette
affirmation par exemple vous noterez ces
mots par exemple comme inventé ou encore
mise en scène ou même ghost hommel gosto
mail c'est le nom d'une ville une ville
qui se trouve au nord-ouest de la
capitale kiev qui se trouve ici coastal
health est ici à proximité de butch à
bout de champ là où l'onu enquête une
centaine d' enquête est actuellement
ouverte pour des crimes de guerre
précisément alors on va revenir sur la
publication viral sur ses publications
virale dont je vous parlais preuve pour
preuve eh bien elles veulent de ses
mises en scène de faux crimes attribués
à moscou elle utilise essentiellement
cette vidéo que l'on va découvrir
ensemble regardez on y voit des
carcasses de voitures pour certaines en
feu on voit aussi un bâtiment en ruines
d'où s'échappent certaines personnes et
ce qui semble être vous le voyez une
équipe de tournage alors s'agit-il d'un
tournage et qu'elle l'origine de cette
vidéo et bien nous avons mené l enquête
on va retourner à la publication virale
dont je vous parlais à regarder parce
que il y à 1 1 10 sur cette publication
virale c'est ici le compte tik tok un
compte tik tok on va se rendre sur ce
compte à tik tok c'est ici et vous allez
voir que cette vidéo on la retrouve ici
dans cette publication une publication
qui date du 8 août et qui évoque
effectivement un tournage agosto mêle la
ville dont je vous parlais tout à
l'heure hyaric fort c'est le nom de ce
compte pour jaroslaw force il est chargé
de casting pour le film reid jeunes of
heroes parce que oui ces scènes eh bien
ce sont des scènes d'un film en
l'occurrence ridge of heroes donc et
lorsqu'on se rend sur la page facebook
officielle de ce film on en apprend un
peu plus sur le contenu il s'agit de a
retracé à l'histoire l'histoire de cinq
personnes cinq portraits donc de ce qui
je cite ont vécu l'enfer à kiev et ce
aux premières semaines de l'offensive
russe en ukraine donc aux alentours du
24 février une production de la société
ukrainienne heidi fine ce qui d'ailleurs
sur son compte instagram à publier
certains à clichés du tournage comme
celui-ci et regarder si vous prenez à la
publication enfin en tout cas l'une des
publications virale vous retrouvez bien
en arrière-plan ce bâtiment en ruine ici
comme ici alors oui il y à bien mises en
scène sauf que dans un cas en
l'occurrence celui ci c'est du cinéma et
en aucun cas il s'agit d'une fabrication
de preuves comme c'est annoncé dans ses
publications alors toujours en août un
l'armée ukrainienne a frappé des
installations russe en crimée et depuis
certains comptes sur les réseaux sociaux
assure que cette offensive a été appuyé
par des actions de propagande oui c'est
ça plusieurs comptes qui soutiennent
clairement l'ukraine face à cette guerre
en russie plusieurs publications qui ont
notamment publié ce cliché regarder et
qui affirment pour certains voire s'en
réjouissent comme cet internaute ici
avec cet excellent nous dit il que ce
cliché a été pris sur le pont de crime
et qui relie donc la russie à la crimée
qui on le rappelle a été annexé en 2014
par la russie qui se ré risque des
hackers ukrainien et réussi à pirater
cet écran que l'on voit ici pour faire
vous le voyez apparaître cette message
presque patriotique finalement welcome
to you cry bienvenue en ukraine alors
qu'en est il réellement est ce qu'il ya
eu un piratage et bien la réponse elle
nous vient de la géolocalisation je vous
renvoie d'ailleurs à cet effet au site
des observateurs de france 24 pour
retrouver toutes les astuces tous les
conseils essentiels est nécessaire pour
bien utiliser les outils en l'occurrence
nous avons utilisé l'outil de google
street view qui permet donc de
visualiser
virtuellement comme son nom indique de
différentes rues différents sites et
d'avoir aussi accès à des photos
géolocalisées alors je vous le disais le
dans les publications en évoque beaucoup
là le pont de de crimée et regarder
lorsque l'on cherche sur google street
view on retrouve effectivement cette
localisation le fait qu'il s'agit bien
du pont de crimée mais vous l'aurez noté
aussi on va même plus loin puisque au
delà de la simple localisation on
retrouve aussi la photo d'origine dès la
publication virale et lorsque vous
faites le comparatif vous pouvez
d'ailleurs à noter plusieurs éléments
communs c'est un peu le jeu des 7
différences finalement il y a ce panneau
qui indique pont de crime et il y a
cette voiture là même que l'on retrouve
ici mais vous aurez noté une différence
elle est ici le message n'existe pas ici
là en l'occurrence il existe tout
simplement parce que là c'est bien une
photo on va trop vite une photo
authentique là où il s'agit tout
simplement d'un grossier photomontage
pour attribuer donc un message
patriotique totalement erronée merci
beaucoup anthony à saint léger et bravo
pour l'utilisation de notre nouvel outil